control program confirmed in a recent  sonar scan of the ocean floor scientists  recorded a self never before heard by  human ears from paramount animation to  save their world over their surface all  right all secondary characters come with  me they must come to ours  that is this place maybe this guy knows  he looks smart he's gonna buy this  not candy if you ain't all that you'd  have enough energy to  why does it sugar gonna wear off this  February Krabby Patties what are you  doing with me formuler you mean  me formula it happens when I'm nervous  the only way to stop a supervillain  let's take him down it is to be colonies  superheroes a bollock guilty  suits me Patrick  talk to me pity I'm seeing a bright  light this is better much thank you  that's the spongebob movie a sponge out  of water in 3d justices first song soon  maybe we should have picked a better  superpower for you Patrick